blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman i want to start today with sort
of two economic stories that are kind of
coming together as one one i find more
interesting one i find less interesting
the first piece is this issue of
inflation and inflation fears and we
again have data which we'll look at that
prices uh went up again in the month of
september the second part of this i
really am kind of struggling to take it
totally seriously um although there is
there is an interesting piece to it
which is
fears of toy shortages for the christmas
season now the reason i have trouble
sort of taking it totally seriously is
given everything that's going on
everything we've had going on with the
pandemic all sorts of different
calamities and crises and and different
things um
if there's not every toy available at
christmas it doesn't strike me as the
absolute worst thing in the world but
it's it's interesting
in so far as it relates to the continued
supply shortages for a number of
different reasons that we've been seeing
so let's start with
the inflation piece um reuters reporting
u.s consumer prices increased solidly in
september
poised to rise further in the months
ahead
amid a surge in the costs of energy
products which would cast doubt on the
federal reserve's view that high
inflation is transitory this has been
the debate is this are we seeing sort of
some catch-up inflation relative to the
declines due to the 2020 pandemic
due to the pandemic in 2020 the
pandemic's still going on but do do the
effects of the pandemic in 2020 or are
we seeing the start of
some real
uh inflation the consumer price index
rose 0.4 percent last month after
climbing 0.3 in august the labor
department said wednesday in the 12
months through september the cpi
increased 5.4
after advancing 5.3 percent year on year
in august
excluding the volatile food and energy
components the cpi climbed 0.2 after
edging up 0.1 so what if you don't
include food and energy
the increase has been very modest
however food and energy are significant
expenses for many households
particularly you know one of the things
about food and energy um
and this we've talked about this before
but i think it bears repeating
there is a sort of regressive aspect to
food and energy spending and what i mean
by that is
if you're really really rich
you're not necessarily
going to be driving that much more you
might have a car that's less energy
efficient or one that's more energy
efficient okay if you're doing private
jet travel then yes if you're very rich
you actually are going to spend a lot
more on fuel but in terms of like
driving a car
or heating your home
yes if you have a significantly bigger
home you'll pay a lot more to heat it
but relative to your income relative to
your net worth it's not going to be that
much more so in that sense energy cost
increases fuel and home heating
electricity for cooling as well they hit
the poor more than they do the rich
similarly with food
okay if you're wealthy you might buy
everything organic at the most expensive
grocery store
but just because you make 50 times more
than someone else you're not likely to
spend 50 times more on food so this idea
of if we exclude these two categories
energy and food the increase isn't that
much well those are categories that
disproportionately affect the middle
class lower middle class and and the
poor
oil prices jumped monday to the highest
level in years expensive energy products
would add to accelerating wage growth in
exerting upward pressure on inflation
the government reported last week that
average hourly earnings increased by the
most in seven months on a year-on-year
basis because of worker shortages
with the number of people voluntarily
quitting jobs at a record high in august
at least 10.4 million unfilled positions
wage inflation is set to rise further so
this is one piece of the story the other
piece which again i'm sort of like okay
i mean it i get it but it's also
it is what it is toy makers warn delays
in stocking retail shelves could create
a four-month holiday hangover
power outages in china a resin shortage
and high labor costs have also strained
the supply of goods and increased prices
the blockage of the suez canal in march
is part of the bottleneck
um
some questions about shares which we
don't care that much about
uh but there may be delays in getting
people toys so what what's the big
picture here
we may be heading towards real inflation
meaning not just rebound relative as an
artifact relative to the pandemic
we said this six months ago
we need to continue watching it now
there's another piece that's important
to understand which is is inflation good
or bad this is sort of like a
fundamental question
if you accept and many of us don't but
if you if i if we accept traditional
economic thinking
based on
at least for now indefinite growth
you want a little bit of inflation why
um some people think no you don't want
prices going up you want prices going
down that's good for people it's good
for consumers or prices stay the same
people
buy stuff
because you expect that prices will be a
little bit higher in the future maybe
not consciously but let me put it a
different way if you're looking for a
car if you're looking for a home if
you're looking for toys
if you expect prices to go down
that would discourage you from buying
right now because if you wait you can
pay less
if everybody did that because they
expected prices to be lower in the
future
nobody would buy stuff and this would
actually create create a deflationary
spiral which could depress wages it can
put small businesses out of business etc
if you have tons of inflation people
just can't afford stuff wages don't keep
up people can't afford stuff so this is
where the mentality of you want a little
bit of inflation that's where wage
growth comes from to the extent that we
have wage growth that's where business
profit comes from et cetera so when we
talk about inflation it's important to
understand that traditional economics
doesn't say
any inflation is bad in fact we have a
sort of global economy and status quo
based on a little bit of inflation you
expect things to be a little more
expensive in the future so you're going
to go out and buy them today and this
creates revenues for businesses with
which they pay employees
the money with which those employees go
and buy things and sort of keep this
train going now if if you don't believe
in unlimited growth
then at some point the paradigm has to
shift uh but in terms of the immediate
impact
we are seeing sectors uh uh experience
inflation that disproportionately affect
uh the middle class lower middle class
and the poor and we'll just have to
continue tracking those data
um tax the rich
is a popular slogan among the left
taxing the wealthiest is actually
quite well supported by americans across
political parties although certainly
less so by republicans although tax the
rich is
relatively popular overall but taxing
the rich is actually difficult if what
we're talking about is collecting taxes
from the rich and what i mean by that is
many of the methods proposed to tax the
rich either wouldn't really tax the rich
because the rich would find ways around
them or they would be completely
impractical so i'll explain
you raise income taxes you say we're
going to raise that top tax rate of on
income from 36 to 39 to 42 to 50 to 60.
okay
most of the very rich aren't earning
their money through income through wages
so they're not actually going to be
impacted
by
an increase to the top income tax rate
they make a lot of money through capital
gains okay well so then you say well
let's raise capital gains uh the rich
making money from dividends and uh
making money from money will have to pay
if we increase the capital gains tax
rate or tax capital gains as we do
income okay well there's a way around
that as well uh the rich can choose not
to realize the capital gains to avoid
those taxes they can wait around for the
next president or the one after that to
lower the tax rate on capital gains or
they can create charitable foundations
which they control or use other
mechanisms okay well you've got the
estate tax for people who die with more
than a million dollars or 22 million for
couples
there we've got them right well
not really because you can reduce tax
liability there as well
with all sorts of other mechanisms
including stepped-up basis delaware
dynasty trusts i could go on and on
as a business owner you can reduce
taxable income by contributing to a
defined benefit plan and then you earn
income from the plan paying taxes on
income later when your income may be
lower but reducing income taxes in the
immediate okay well hold on so then
let's do a wealth tax let's tax people's
assets even unrealized gains on those
assets i've already explained why i
think it's untenable and some of you
disagree with me
um many times for the very wealthy net
worth is tied up either in their
business in physical assets in accounts
receivable um
you
in stocks with unrealized gains
you may not actually have the liquid
assets to cover a wealth tax and then
imagine that you pay such a tax on
stocks you haven't sold and then next
year the market crashes
and you lose value in those stocks are
you entitled to a refund on the
net worth tax that you paid as i've said
before i believe it's completely
unfeasible i think there's essentially
no chance that what elizabeth warren is
proposing on a wealth tax passes and
part of what i'm getting to here
is something called the dynamic tax
model
when you do a tax model and you score it
how much will we collect
you really should do it dynamically
meaning you account for how people's
behavior will change based on the tax
plan so i'll give you an example if
right now we say listen if you look at
people's income right now
if we were to raise the top marginal tax
rate from 37 to 45
we'd collect 200 billion dollars i'm
just making these numbers up
that only holds if we assume nobody
changes their behavior but the truth is
if you announced the tax is changing
from 37 to 45 percent that top tax rate
many people subject to the top tax rate
would reduce their income
take it in stock
deferred compensation move personal
expenses to business expenses etc so you
need to score these proposals
dynamically to account for changes in
behavior and when you do that you
realize that the actual government
revenue change from a lot of these
proposals is much smaller than what we
might immediately imagine okay great so
these are all the problems
how do we actually collect taxes from
the rich
i actually don't know
because just about every individual
change that i've read about can at least
be partially defeated somewhat mitigated
and even if not people always can
abandon the u.s or whatever country has
the tax and go elsewhere now it's not
that easy to do in the united states you
may have to renounce your citizenship in
the united states to avoid taxation in
the united states if you're a citizen
but
let's talk about what might actually
work
my conclusion
after studying this for a very long time
is if you really want to collect taxes
from the rich
you and other countries
need to basically take an all of the
above approach to make it really
difficult to avoid
taxation
it's not even going to be impossible but
you've got to start calling people's
bluff about leaving the country for
example i think that that's what it
would take so you've got to raise the
top marginal tax rate on income
you've got a tax capital gains as income
you've got to eliminate the stepped-up
basis for the estate tax i've talked
about it before
we don't i'm not going to explain it in
this segment but there i have segments
on it you've got to put in a more
aggressive alternative minimum tax for
higher earners you've got to do it all
together and say listen if you really
want to avoid this stuff you'll have to
leave and maybe other countries will do
the same thing by the way so then where
where are you leaving to
and most people aren't actually going to
abandon their country in this case the
united states and you're going to be
able to pick up some taxes from all of
these different things i don't think
there's really any other way to reliably
collect taxes from the rich i understand
passing policy that targets the rich
but actually collecting is the difficult
part if you have a better idea
let me know but i think that that's what
it would take reminder we are six days
from the david pakman show live town
hall this will be streaming live tuesday
october 19th
6 pm eastern we'll open up the phone
lines for a while we will be streaming
live only on the david pakman show
second channel
called pacmanlive
you can find it at youtube.com
pacmanlive
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
all right let's uh let's keep going on a
bunch of different policy things that
i've been wanting to talk about and i'm
glad to have the opportunity to talk
about today let's talk a little bit
about title 42.
title 42 is something that was created
under donald trump's cdc
to very quickly remove people from the
united states without actually going
through the deportation process under
the guise of public health
and um numerous legal opinions are that
it's being misused or it shouldn't even
exist in the par in the first place but
the joe biden administration is using
title 42 to remove people as well and we
should be if we were critical of trump
using it we should be critical of joe
biden using it as well so let's look at
a relatively recent time article about
this
biden is expelling immigrants of
migrants on covet 19 grounds but health
experts say that's all wrong
despite sharp criticism from top
officials and allies within the
democratic party president biden is
continuing to expel hundreds of
thousands of migrants arriving at the
u.s mexico border using a specialized
public health order that allows
officials to circumvent the normal
trappings of immigration procedure
including asylum interviews the biden
administration is defending its
controversial use of the order called
title 42.
arguing in court that summary expulsions
are quote necessary
due to the ongoing risks of transmission
and spread of covet 19 but
a growing cacophony of top public health
experts are calling foul there's no
evidence that a policy allowing for mass
expulsions prevents the spread of covid
they argue and it may in fact have the
opposite effect by rounding up and
detaining hundreds of thousands of
migrants in large groups cbp which does
not offer coveted testing for migrants
may actually be stoking the transmission
of the disease migrants often spend days
and weeks in crowded facilities before
they are transported and expelled
the title 42 order fuels the pandemic
says julia kohler assistant professor of
pediatrics it does not promote public
health it is opposing public health
top biden administration officials also
appear to be distancing themselves from
the policy uh alejandro mayorkas said
title 42 quote is not an immigration
policy that we in this administration
would embrace
but we view it as a public health
imperative as the cdc has so ordered
uh remember title 42
was passed by the cdc
under trump
uh i'm sorry no
title 42 was passed in 1944 as part of
the public health service act
but it was used by trump to expel people
without going through the full process
of requesting asylum
getting that asylum interview if it's
rejected going through a deportation
it's basically basically like a sort of
do not pass go do not collect 200 just a
direct expulsion
under the order the cdc can temporarily
suspend the introduction of persons into
the u.s
when the cdc director determines the
existence of a communicable disease in a
foreign country
or places or place creates a serious
danger of the introduction of disease in
the us the order has never been used
this way before nor was it intended as
an immigration tool
in april of 2020 he wrote uh stanford
law professor lucas gutentag wrote never
before in over 75 years has it been used
as a substitute or mechanism for
regulating admission under the
immigration laws
this is complicated
uh by the reality
that
one can
um you have to read between the lines
although it's pretty obvious
that this was being used by trump as a
way to enforce his immigration policy
rather than an actual public health
measure and part of the way we know it
is that some of the reading between the
lines
is
obvious because trump didn't really take
the virus seriously at the same time
that he was not talking about masking
pushing back against closures praising
ron desantis for opening florida early
for i think it was wrestling and ufc or
whatever the case was
trump was using title 42
to justify direct expulsions
circumventing the actual asylum and
deportation process on the basis of
public health so it was very transparent
that donald trump uh
was was using this without actually
caring about the public health piece and
just saying hey here's a great way to
get people directly out of the country
unfortunately the biden administration
has been doing the exact same thing um i
think that there are sort of two issues
here does it work to stop the spread of
kovid
and is it morally the right thing to do
i i think the answer is no on both in
terms of does it help stop the spread of
covid
as many health experts have weighed in
including the ones i just quoted it
doesn't seem to
you are even though the premise is
direct and rapid expulsion it still
takes weeks if not months and during
that time folks are crowded together
without being tested for covid you may
actually be spreading covet by using
this policy that's number one number two
what about morally
uh i think it doesn't pass the moral
test either
um we are
we should
actually
adjudicate
asylum requests
etc in the proper normal channels
uh period
and
while we were critical of the trump
administration for doing this we must be
critical of the biden administration for
doing it i think it's wrong either way i
don't care if it's a democrat or a
republican in the white house
if you disagree with me if you think
it's okay to be using title 42 on this
basis
then i want to hear from you
this is an absolutely wacky story
we have now learned
that donald trump was going to appoint
his daughter ivanka
to be president of the world bank
until steven mnuchin intervened
there are a number of reports explaining
that back in 2019
donald trump
told the atlantic about all the jobs
that he wanted to give his daughter
ivanka even ones where she wouldn't be
qualified for an internship
and we have learned per the intercept
that the idea was what about ivanka as
president of the world bank
in january of 2019 you might remember
that jim yong kim
announced he would be stepping down from
his role as president of the world bank
going to a very cushy gig on wall street
at a private equity firm
as the white house moved to select its
new leader
one name very dear to trump's heart kept
floating around his daughter ivanka
it never came to fruition with ivanka
later telling reporters that though her
father raised the subject she declined
to pursue it because she was happy with
her work as senior adviser but
two sources not authorized to speak
publicly tell the intercept that it went
well beyond beltway chatter trump wanted
ivanka as world bank president but it
was treasury secretary steven mnuchin
who blocked her getting into that role
spokespeople for mnuchin and ivanka
didn't respond to the intercept's
request for comment needed neither did
the world bank or the trump organization
she didn't end up doing it
but she did end up helping steven
mnuchin and then chief of staff mick
mulvaney
to choose the successor
how can anyone seriously talk about
hunter biden
when these are the things that donald
trump was thinking of doing and to some
degree he was actually doing these
things i mean remember
i think was it the g20 or the g8 g8 i
believe ivanka sat in for then secretary
of state rex tillerson at a g8 meeting
that's insane
remember the cringeworthy video where
ivanka awkwardly sidled up to this
conversation
with the chair of the international
monetary fund christine lagarde and
german chancellor angela merkel
and british prime minister theresa may
and french president emmanuel macron at
the g20 and everybody just looked kind
of uncomfortably and and said what that
what
why why is ivanka here lagarde in
particular seemed disgusted by it
and
it makes no sense that ivanka would even
be considered for such a role
the depths of
corruption
and nepotism and the self-serving
instincts of the trump family really
know no bounds and for me the only sort
it's not surprising trump thought of
this it's not surprising he wanted to do
it
the only surprising thing to me
is that trump allowed himself to be
talked out of it by steven mnuchin
when steven mnuchin is the voice of
reason
you know you must be coming up with a
really bad idea and truly i mean as far
as mnuchin is concerned
i've always seen mnuchin more as an
opportunist
the guy is not dumb at all he's just an
opportunistic finance guy socially
awkward strange delivery
willing to work for trump for what he
saw as his own personal gain for which
he deserves criticism for sure
but by the standards of kind of like
modern education and what's appropriate
etc steven mnuchin pretty smart guy
and it's not a surprise that mnuchin
realized the absurdity of what donald
trump was thinking here but
the the the nepotistic uh instincts of
trump really know no bounds and um when
when we consider particularly in the
context of it hunter is the problem the
problem is hunter biden
uh and then we see i mean listen kushner
and ivanka
were senior advisers to trump
imagine for a moment if joe biden
announced that hunter biden was going to
become his senior advisor or i mean
imagine for a second if at a g8
instead instead of the actual secretary
of state there was video and there were
pictures released of hunter biden
sitting there where the secretary of
state uh is actually supposed to be
sitting it would be what a week two
weeks three weeks they did seven to ten
days on dr seuss on fox news just
imagine and trump wanted ivanka as
president of the world bank and if he
comes back in 2024 i'm telling you right
now
the degree to which the nepotism and the
self-serving and the corruption will
increase
is inconceivable to us it will be insane
if he is rewarded with a second term
what we will see in terms of the
nepotism let's hope it doesn't happen
but uh very good reporting there from
the intercept and vanity fair and others
we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show instagram
you can find us on instagram at
davidpakmanshow you can find me on
instagram at david.pacman as well
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
so we spoke yesterday about the sort of
disturbing reality
that
at this late stage in the game you still
see most prominent republicans
uh quite fervently
feverantly and feverishly
behind donald trump we had this rally in
iowa over the weekend chuck grassley was
there saying trump's great all this
different stuff it's very very
concerning
and one of the ways in which republicans
signal
their at least for now continued public
loyalty to trump whatever they believe
privately they may hate the guy
privately think he's terrible for the
republican party whatever right but the
way you signaled that at least publicly
you're still behind trump
is when you're asked
did donald trump have the election
stolen from him
you don't say no you come up with
anything you can to avoid saying no and
that's exactly what radical
bomb-throwing republican congressman
steve scalise did over the weekend when
he was interviewed by chris wallace now
it took me a couple days to get to this
we were off monday for the federal
holiday and i didn't have time yesterday
but i want to get to it today it
happened on sunday chris wallace just
keeps asking steve scalise
uh was the election stolen from donald
trump or will you say that it was not
that that joe biden simply won
and steve scalise goes through every
single iteration of how you don't say no
so let's just jump into it we'll go
through these examples and we'll talk
about them and it's interesting to see
how chris wallace handles it
but really for me the more interesting
part is to analyze the language that
scalise uses
to answer questions that aren't the ones
being asked
in order to avoid simply saying it
wasn't stolen from donald trump let's
jump in u.s capital let me ask you one
last question in this regard clearly
there were irregularities in the last
election there are irregularities in all
elections but i i want to ask you a
specific question do you think the 2020
election
was stolen from donald trump and and to
be i i'm not gonna just i'm not i'm
gonna try not to jump in all the time
the way i've been saying this is
anecdotal irregularities aside which
there would always be in an election in
a country of 330 million people do we
have any evidence that the
irregularities in even one state rose to
the level of being materially
substantive as far as who the winner was
that's that's the core
and and continue continuing to make that
charge not
having states do election reforms but
specifically making this charge that the
election was stolen
do you think that that hurts undermines
american democracy
well chris i've been very clear from the
beginning if you look at a number of
states they didn't follow their state
past laws that govern the election for
president that is what the united states
constitution says now that's that's
that's absurd
think about even what steve scalise says
there
states didn't follow their own rules
which is a matter of the u.s
constitution no it's not
it's quite literally a matter of the
state rules it's not a u.s
constitutional issue this is backwards
and sideways and nonsense now the other
issue is
if states didn't follow their own rules
would that be a reason to give that
state to trump is that evidence that
trump actually won a state in which the
quote rules weren't followed so first
you have to prove that then you have to
prove it's materially substantive then
you have to prove that it would have
made the election go a different way if
there were people who voted absentee and
then moved and then didn't call and say
i no longer live in the state
that may be something that took place it
may not
but then to say and that means trump
should have won the state is not backed
by the evidence they don't say that the
states determine what the rules are they
say the state legislatures determine
that the state's all certified they
didn't follow those state legislative
this the states all certify those
legislative rules
right but at the end of the day are we
going to follow what the constitution
says or not i hope we get back to what
the constitution is remember this is not
about the u.s it's just it just it's not
about the u.s constitution he's talking
about state rule state certification but
clearly in a number of states they
didn't follow those legislatively so do
you think the election was gone
what i said is there are states that
didn't follow their legislatively set
rules that's what the united states
constitution says and so then and i
think there are a lot of people that
want us to get back to what the
constitution says
we should be doing not just with
elections with a lot of other things too
this is where trumpists end up repeating
they ignored the constitution in the
2020 election because they hear people
like steve scalise say it without
explaining it and they just
yeah i don't know
and then there's some people that want
to just ignore what the constitution
says and do their own thing you know
that's been a debate that's been going
on in this country for a long time but
don't just get back to the constitution
i i have a
getting back to the constitution is
different than did trump have the
election stolen from him and was he the
rightful winner
two totally different things out there
there was a rally for president trump
yesterday and a number of people said
joe biden's not my president uh donald
trump is my president
i i guess the question is do you think
the election not last time i promised do
you think the election was stolen or not
i understand you think there were
irregularities and things that need to
be fixed do you think the election was
stolen and it's not just irregular it's
states that did not follow the law
which the constitution you guys think
he'll answer this time what do you think
says they're supposed to follow when you
see states like georgia cleaning up some
of the mess and people calling that jim
crow law that's a flat out lie i think
absolutely no law against that sort of
thing all right yeah but but the law
says again guys he's not going to answer
the question he's not going to answer
the question
this is how you play coy
and avoid the wrath of trump supporters
and avoid the wrath of trump himself
i don't think there's really any way
that steve scalise believes this crap in
any literal sense i don't think steve
scalise believes donald trump actually
won the election i i just don't think so
and adam kinzinger and others have said
almost no republicans believe that
maybe a couple i think you know maybe
marjorie taylor green i don't know uh
but there is just no way
that steve scalise believes that but he
doesn't want the wrath of trump
supporters or trump he's signaling his
loyalty they see this as a war as i've
said before
where maybe you've got a lie or maybe
you've got a claim to believe something
you don't really believe or whatever the
case may be
this was three four attempts by chris
wallace to just get a simple answer and
the whole point is not answering is how
you prove your loyalty not answering is
how you prove your loyalty and steve
scalise is doing it uh and we'll see how
long they keep doing it it appears as
though it's going to be for quite some
time
okay i want to talk next about
the party
that claims to support our police
we must never defund we must never
restrict we must never limit the
techniques and tools and tactics that
police are able to use
and yet
they have been persistently and
consistently attacking the officers that
were there trying to defend the capital
on january 6th of this year the day of
the trump riots
we're going to look at a clip today
of newsmax host greg kelly
calling the police officers who
testified at those hearings about the
trump riots quote crisis actors
now we we even have to talk about that
term crisis actors crisis actors is a
term that in sort of general popular
culture to the extent that it's a term
people are even familiar with was kind
of popularized by extreme conspiracy
theorists like alex jones
i think my first introduction to the
term crisis actor was when alex jones
alleged that the parents of the victims
of the shooting at sandy hook in newtown
connecticut newton newtown i always
forget how it's spelled and pronounced
opposite uh under barack obama that they
were crisis actors they weren't really
the parents of the victims or there
weren't really victims and these were
high whatever
that's my first real
exposure to the term crisis actors and
in this segment greg kelly uses the term
to refer to the police officers now
remember greg kelly and republicans they
support the police and all of that stuff
okay let's take a listen uh as for trump
you know where he was on january 6 he
gave that speech i always said he had a
great alibi i mean number one he's not
at the capitol and number two he
specifically told people to uh
keep it peaceful right i know that
everyone here will soon be marching over
to the capitol building
to peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard
now anybody who doesn't realize trump's
talking in code to his followers
you've got to understand the way dog
whistles work but that's not even the
focus of this segment all right so i'm
not a lawyer but here's what i would do
i would print off a picture of those
four
police officers at the
hearing a couple of months ago these
guys these some people call them crisis
actors i think that was a pretty apt
description
totally unprofessional
this is a law enforcement more than a
political question about january 6 in my
opinion a security matter uh but i would
not want to go in front of this phony
baloney committee and by phony baloney i
mean
this is phony baloney think about what
you have to believe
in order to follow these people in any
real way right the world is just full of
crisis actors and a false flags the
sandy hook shooting years ago they say
that was a false flag with crisis actors
the the impetus was to take people's
guns which by the way didn't happen
record gun sales weren't even able to
pass universal background checks after
sandy hook
the january six riots that was a false
flag by antifa or liberals to make
trumpists look bad
but it was also peaceful trumpists that
conflict they don't care it was just it
was a false flag the police officers who
were hurt
scared abused
they are crisis actors also to make
trumpists look bad but consider what
that even means crisis actor the police
officers were crisis actors does that
mean they're not really police officers
or they are but they're lying about what
happened or the videos
depicting what happened were staged like
what does it even mean to say that the
police officers are crisis actors it
doesn't matter
the government that supposedly
is in charge
really isn't in charge as the basis for
a lot of this we talked about that
shadow government conspiracy yesterday
it's a it's a kind of package of
conspiracy theories sometimes it's
called deep state uh sometimes it's
trilateral commission illuminati the
bilderbergs the jews the vatican whoever
they're really in charge not the
president and the vice president and the
normal centers of power once you buy
into that general idea
it's very easy to be
convinced or tricked into believing that
the so-called police officers were
crisis actors they were hired it was
staged in some way shape or form and
what's kind of notable about this
is they don't even realize that they are
playing right into the propaganda of
foreign nations when they promote this
stuff including russia's disinformation
campaigns the centers of this
type of conspiracy in the u.s right now
are
uh right-wing evangelicals love and
spread this stuff
older white republicans love and spread
this stuff authoritarians just kind of
like fascist dictator wannabe
authoritarian types right-wing media
like fox newsmax oan although
there are some
of the republicans who don't subscribe
to this stuff
but this is exactly the type of stuff
that russia works to spread the us isn't
really in control the u.s is being
controlled by someone else you can't
trust american democracy democracy has
failed you can't trust the election
results this is the putin russia game
they don't even realize that they're
they're playing right into it out of one
side of their mouth they say
russiagate it was fake it was trumped up
it was rachel maddow and whoever but at
the same time they're spreading the
exact stuff
that the russian disinformation
propaganda campaigns want to spread and
if there's really a crisis actor isn't
it the people on newsmax pretending to
be news people like that's really the
acting that's going on
and sadly it's tricking a lot of people
a lot of people are falling for it and
they're not even questioning it in any
serious way so this is the latest now
the police officers who they claim to
support
are the crisis actors and then just like
as a final point which it must be made
anytime we talk about right-wing
conspiracies about either the military
or the police law enforcement etc
they have the stated principle that they
support the troops and they support the
police etc
it's not really a principle they abide
by they abandon it as soon
as it's inconvenient to support the
police or support the troops in this
case if they support the police they're
supporting these officers saying it was
a trumpist violent madhouse doesn't work
so the principal gets abandoned
immediately they don't actually care
about the principles
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right so we can
say a lot of different things about uh
steve bannon a former breitbart
propagandist a former trump advisor we
can say he's an immoral person we can
say he's a disgusting individual we can
say his politics are all wrong and all
of those things would be true
but steve bannon is not a stupid guy
when it just comes to basic fundamental
uh statements about how elections work
for example and that's why i'm not fully
getting
why steve bannon is continuing to say
that any day now donald trump is going
to be back in the white house and in
fact on his recent program
the war room on real america's voice
steve bannon said trump's going to be
back in 2022 or maybe even before now of
course donald trump is not going to be
back as president in 2022 or maybe even
before
and i know that steve bannon knows that
so why is he saying it let's consider
that as we watch this clip take a look
at this the quiet part out loud today
the anxiety the hangry the pearl
clutching is the democratic party's fear
of the return of trump
that's what all these committees are
that's what they're trying to do that's
what this all the justice department is
this the senate that dick durbin's got
the long face
the return of trump and it ain't going
to be in 2024
it's going to be in 2022 or maybe before
as we start the decertification process
out in arizona let the americans there
is no such process okay
now
i know uh steve bannon doesn't believe
that he just there's no way he he's he's
we can make a lot of criticisms of him
but he doesn't believe that
so is this the same as when steve
scalise won't answer when chris wallace
asks him again and again and again was
the election stolen from trump and steve
scalise answers every question other
than the one that's actually being asked
is it steve bannon's signaling i don't
know because steve bannon doesn't need
trump's support to be re-elected for
example steve bannon is not in the same
position so why is steve bannon saying
this
now as far as the facts
remember that there's no mechanism that
makes this possible there's no you know
the line of succession is joe biden
kamala harris nancy pelosi
no one is doubting
i mean maybe they are but it's not part
of the story that nancy pelosi's
election in 2020 was also fraudulent
nancy pelosi is
uh duly elected
so if by some unknown means
that we don't even know
you get the presidential election thrown
out nancy pelosi becomes president it's
not donald trump the supreme court will
not be reinstating donald trump no one
will be reinstating donald trump i know
steve bannon knows this horrible person
but he's not this stupid so why is he
saying it maybe he wants clicks and this
gets him clicks i don't know
maybe it's a signal to people to prepare
for another violent coup attempt
neither is a great scenario i think the
coup is worse from those two options
simply trying to monetize a dumb
audience is one thing but trying to
weaponize that audience into attempting
another riot i think is far worse quite
frankly it's not like there have really
been major consequences at least yet for
the rioters so why wouldn't you go for
another coup attempt if steve bannon
tells you that maybe it'll work
also on decertifying arizona
whenever
you run out of ideas or your ideas are
totally rejected by reality
what they do is they come up with a new
word that people don't yet know much
about so they think maybe that could
happen the new word is decertification
of arizona will never happen it it's not
a thing and remember that even if it did
even if decertifying the arizona results
of the 2020 election in what is almost
2022 now even if they came up with a way
to do it
flipping arizona from trump to biden
doesn't change who won in 2020 anyway uh
arizona's 11 electoral votes joe biden
had 306 you need 270 to win without
arizona biden still has 295 so it's a
layer of nonsense upon layer of nonsense
and people fall for it and whether the
point is money
or it's to prepare people to get violent
again the next time that this doesn't
happen
or it's because steve bannon believes he
has to do this because it'll help him in
some way curry favor with donald trump
which maybe he still needs for some
reason i don't know
whatever the reason people
fall for this stuff
and it's extraordinarily dangerous and
it doesn't seem like it's going to stop
anytime soon
before we get to today's voicemail
segment
um i want to get to a couple of clips of
mike pillow as i refer to him or my
pillow ceo mike lindell the latest
conspiracy theory from mike lindell it's
idiotic it's really a doozy but it's an
opportunity to remind people that some
much repeated talking points have long
been debunked about the 2020 election
we're gonna look uh starting with this
first clip we have a couple of different
clips to look at
in this first clip mike pillow says
that an 850 year old person voted in the
2020 election as well as 2 000 people
who were 200 years of age or older
this is dumb for a few reasons some of
which are obvious some of which are less
obvious let's take a listen well i'm
going to give an example today and i'm
not going to say what state
uh we pulled up we we put from the voter
rolls to one of our team we have a team
that goes through all of it now with
this other system that pulls up all
anomalies what i mean by that is five
people voting for the same address um
uh or five of the same names um
i'll give an example today two thousand
six hundred and fifty people
over the age of a hundred now you might
say well well that's that could be that
could be
two thousand and we're over two hundred
wouldn't you like to live in that state
right
okay well it would tell us what state it
is mike 200 some years old so so
obviously they one guy they were 200
years old these people they are voting
are 200 years old of course they're
obviously not they're obviously deceased
but one guy was 850 years old okay um
and these are and these are effects you
can get them you can get them from your
own state's thing now you have that they
remember you have non-resident support
right but basically it pulls out all
these
um deviations anomalies and they're
stacked up like cordwood and then we
have the canvases so then we we back it
up so let's say you have an address like
we did like in wisconsin remember it was
23 000 people yeah wisconsin
imagine having to be the co-host or
whatever
and uh playing along with this stuff it
would be great to know the name of the
supposedly 850 year old person and the
state in which they supposedly voted but
sadly mike pillow doesn't give us that
information now
why does this not make sense so the of
course it would be fraud he's not saying
that was really an 850 year old person
who voted he's saying
someone who would be 850 years old today
shows is registered as having voted
even though we're not aware of people
living to 850 years old so clearly it's
fraud i hate to add some facts here
but
when an 850 year old person would have
been alive
the united states didn't exist there
were no elections so how would you
register to vote how did the supposedly
850 year old person
ever register to vote such that they
would even have been on voter rolls to
begin with
when the united states didn't exist when
they were still alive
it doesn't make any sense it's it's
pre-columbian
um
incredible
the next clip is and he was starting to
say this when we paused in the next clip
mike pillow says that 23 000 dead people
voted
with a specific prison everyone use all
23 000 used the same prison address to
vote i can read
logan if you can pull up i'm going to
show you guys in wisconsin just an
example how 23 000 people general voted
using a prison address and use the same
phone number now those people and a lot
of them were
people we turned out as we as we dove
into it they don't they're not alive
anymore they just use their names
obviously right and uh and they don't
live in wisconsin yeah
um so what's the opportunity here the
opportunity is to do a real review of
the whole dead people voting thing this
was extensively looked at we talked
about it in the aftermath of the
election
uh michigan was one place where there
were claims dead voters all these dead
ten thousand dead people voted now i
encourage you to check out the bbc
article
u.s election 2020 the dead voters in
michigan who are still alive
the bbc
started
with the the ten thousand names posted
to twitter
supposedly dead people who voted
and they started investigating some of
those and what they found what that was
that this was essentially a combination
of
people who were just still alive the bbc
picked 31 of the people
um
30 30
and uh they did 30 names and then added
the oldest person on the list of the 31
names uh people supposedly dead
bbc spoke to 11 or to a family member
who said no no i'm still alive they are
still alive for 17 others there simply
was no record of their death at all and
they found evidence that they were alive
after the alleged date of death
three people on the list were dead and
they looked at those later i believe
they they died after casting their
absentee ballot
and then in some cases it was a question
of like junior senior confusion so this
has been
widely widely debunked and it resurfaces
in different forms
now it's
the the names of 23 000 dead people
were registered
as being at a prison
and then voted from there why would
anyone do that why would if you're
looking to
vote in the names of 23 000 dead people
why would you say all of their addresses
are a prison that would be that would
call attention to what you're doing you
have to believe that the people who
quote stole the election are both
incredible criminal geniuses in order to
pull it off
but at the same time dumb enough to
register 23 000 dead voters at the same
address
just none of it makes sense and mike
pillow won't stop and unfortunately it's
going to be with us for a while
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a doozy of a voicemail from this
anti-vaccine woman who keeps calling in
this may actually be the nuttiest
anti-vaxx call we've ever had take a
listen to this
okay i forgot a word i remembered it
it's called aspirate
look up
you
mr dr pacman
bye remember i never claim
to be a doctor nor to be
formulating the things i say about the
vaccine on my own i'm merely reporting
on that which we get from
epidemiologists immunologists public
health researchers etc
why do uh
intra-muscular
injections require
um
god aspiration
go ahead look it up okay look it up in
any of your [ __ ] medical journals
mr genius pacman my journers
this dr john
campbell
a doctorate in nursing
is not a a flooky kooky yeah by the way
i mean without even giving my opinion on
john campbell i've seen some of his
videos he has an interesting youtube
channel
some of his videos are are interesting
to me some are less interesting
um
he he has a phd in health science and
like the teaching of of health science
um and a doctorate in philosophy so i
mean it's just we should just mention
he's not a medical doctor that that's
not praise or an attack
but even just you know the again dr jill
biden shouldn't be called doctor i you
be the judge you be the judge as to when
we should use the term doctor when we're
talking about someone who's talking
about medicine i don't know no he's not
there are numerous studies out there
like like you're saying there aren't any
there's like one study out of wherever
you're so [ __ ] foolish
it's listed as uh
one of the most essential drugs in the
world health organization
yeah i think she's talking about
ivermectin and of course that doesn't
mean it's works for covid it's written
off label all the time
you know why would they give a dog the
same penicillin that they give a human
why
you know what you know what this is all
about this is all about selling
vaccinations to people and making
billions we not only paid for the
vaccines to be developed
now we got to pay the mother
like big bucks
right
so um i i don't think there's any
bringing her back
i i just don't think there's any
bringing her back if you think there
might be
please explain to me how
on today's bonus show producer pat
makes his triumphant return
we will hear what he's been up to we
will talk about the resignation of nfl
coach john gruden after uh homophobic
racist and misogynistic emails
we will talk about how the new york city
school's vaccine mandate is going and we
will talk about the approval by the fda
of another rapid antigen test what's
different about this rapid test for
covid
we will discuss in detail
all of those stories on today's bonus
show sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code better21 to save if you want you
don't have to you decide and we will
speak to you on the bonus show in mere
moments
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com
david pakman